martin's really been a different type of
pitcher at home
night and day good pitcher on the road
not so much at home close to a six era
at home
wave and a miss another one of those
swings and down he goes hacking they see
the three finger grip
running away a little bit from stan to
pick up that strikeout so
bruno stays at second base le mayhew at
second
and cut on and missed he struck him out
he gets in swing mode just don't throw
him a strike domingo hermann on the
mound at fenway park here on a sunday
afternoon you can see this will be his
17th start on the season a little bit of
a mixed bag as era has been going in the
wrong direction
swing and a miss
swings over the change up duran down on
strikes yeah raphael just two for 15 off
him he goes down on the knee you get him
got the umpire that drilled gucci oni
fastball in cross seam pulls it out
there looks like it got him in the thigh
misses his thigh and catches his inner
thigh and he went down like he was shot
debra's
yeah he's doing everything he can to get
out of the way meanwhile the other guys
should be on the ground gucci tony got
plug
he's eyeing his fourth k
looks like the cutter
and he gets it he sits him down another
one looking which as you say is his
specialty
now lamar is looking back i don't know
what he was looking at could have been
looking at the umpire because this ball
is almost over the middle of the plate
see where vazquez is set up now watch
where it breaks no squawking there no
which so far has been
really really impressive here's the 2-2
and that's in there strike three
what a gift this ball way inside
guccione that's the second one he's
given
perez today yeah that that one as a
hitter you have to question
i mean you have no choice
but to question that
that ball's inside
it's just
clearly inside
punched out torres on a cutter outside
so that's two pitches he's given him
today
well he's odor who struck out his first
time the speedy allen at second and
stanton at first with two out
scoreless top of the third
that one is looped into center field it
is a base hit allen scores easily
stanton stops at second hits a bloop rbi
single 4-0 door and it's one-nothing
yanks absolutely love that at bat stay
inside and even though you get jammed
you can get a single up the middle
two-seam fastball see where the hands
are inside jam
just get enough to get the yankees on
the board instead of pulling off this
ball and rolling it over into the shift
labor torres leads off for the yanks as
we hit the fourth inning
[Applause]
line drive base hit to left field that's
going to roll all the way to the green
monster
and torres has himself a lead-off double
there's that cutter that you know a lot
of hitters have given up on gleber
stayed with it and enough wood on it uh
hook it over dever's head
and it's a funny little angle down there
because if you pull it it'll hit that
sidewall and come out for a single but
if it rides the wall gets to the green
monster
easy
double boston plays the infield up
early in the game i don't want to fall
behind by two runs don't blame him
now here is archela
and the pitch is cut on hit in the air
to deep left that ball heading toward
the wall is off the top of the wall
torres scores a shella
holds it first with a long single when i
say long that ball was high off the wall
didn't miss by all that much of a home
run so it's a base hit and an rbi and
the yanks take a two nothing lead and
welcome back george shelly he's looking
at the top of the wall to see what the
world happened there when you hit it
there and that is that's not unusual
that happens a lot he actually thought
maybe he had it uh as a as a home run
and started running he was looking he
didn't miss by much i bet he missed by
less than a foot
all right brother
got five endings left
swinging a bit better get it done
it's a long time
oh but as we sit and talk and tell
stories herman is throwing a great game
and again pitching up in the strike zone
duran
smart smart pitching
now here's the o2 to debra's
struck him out swinging high fastball
that fastball 94 but in the right spot
up
martinez with a fly ball to center in
the second hole for one
and he grounds one left side backhanded
by torres the jump throw got him
beautiful play by gleber torres yeah
these are big plays and big outs i mean
in a two to nothing game getting that
lead off out and coney you can talk
about it's such a big thing
you gets a guy on first to start a rally
it's a completely different inning
yeah first pitch change up labor
cheating to the hole goes and gets it
two nothing yankees over the red sox
in the sixth inning aldor
swings at the first pitch and drills it
deep to right center field that ball is
gone
see ya home run door and it's
three-nothing yankees
oh door
hey homers he had singled in a run now
he homers and the yankees take a
three-nothing lead
the 12th home run and the 30th rbi for
odor
strike three cordero down looking
again mix it up once in a while no
patterns he's been going to that
curveball with two strikes but not here
94 right on the upper part of the strike
zone again
ground ball
to urchella
through six
vermont is not allowed to hit to the red
sox
he couldn't hold up on the breaking ball
and he strikes out for the third time
against jeremiah
[Applause]
swinging to miss ball gets away from
sanchez and he just jogs after it as
bogarts
reaches first
so that'll be a strikeout
and he probably reaches on a pass ball
the o2 that's what ain't gonna miss got
him
another curveball three strikeouts in
the inning but just two outs
now the one two struck him out swinging
breaking ball he struck out four men in
the inning one reached on a pass ball
tremendous no runs no hits
and alex verdugo desperate to change
that
as we go to the bottom of the eighth
inning there's a drive out to right
field allen gets turned around racing
back it is over his head
gradual into second slides in with a
double
and a red sox break it up on an extra
base hit by alex fordugo there you have
it
red sex trying to rally against this
bullpen lewis again out of the stretch
his pitch hit hard down the left field
line toward the corner fair ball off the
wall in the hop it'll score a run
verdugo is in and the throw to second is
too high and renfro slides in with a
double that was a bullet off the bat of
hunter renfrow back to back two base
hits christian vasquez the hitters
little looping line drive shallow right
center that's going to fall for a hit
they're waving renfro around and he will
score as allen had a little trouble
playing it in shallow right center
it's a bloop single
for christian vasquez and it's a four to
two game
the red sox have suddenly hit the gas
pedal double double single single
nobody out
there's a shot down the line
baskets will score
cordero diving into third into second
base is hernandez this is a one-run game
he did it again put the ball in play
that's what the yankees did yesterday
got some blue hits but it was effective
just put it in play flowecky he does
chops slowly to short it'll tie the game
torres lops the first for the out it's
4-4
as cordero scores and on to third base
goes kk hernandez sox were down
four to nothing about 30 seconds ago and
we're getting no hits
amazing
high fly
along the line
allen creeping over tk back to tag
here's the throw and he is safe at home
and the red sox lead it five to four
incredible
how many headlong dives have we seen the
last few days
two down a 2-1
swung on and popped up here comes
debra's
raffy along the line he's got it and the
red sox win 5-4 they beat the yankees
win the series they have clinched the
season series that's the game of the
year that is absolutely the game of the
year